[Music]
hi youtubers is Charlie and all glory to
hypnotoad I mean hi youtubers it's
Charlie and I got to see the Futurama
finale live with the cast and crew it
was all part of this big live event and
almost everyone from the show was there
with the exception of katey sagal so
here's my recap of what happened and to
review that episode so the live event
was actually at the YouTube space in LA
it was hosted by Chris Hardwick and
Nerdist so if you've listened to his
podcast or if you've seen his show The
Nerdist it looked a lot like that so
they answered a lot of questions from
the fans and told a lot of funny stories
one really funny thing that showrunner
David X Cohen actually said is that the
person who directed the series finale
for Futurama
this year actually directed the series
finale for Futurama
three other times before that's right
the show had been basically cancelled
three other times during its run it's
been on since 1998 so that's actually a
long time but he said if you get really
good at directing the last episode ever
of a TV show something is really really
wrong with your career Mac renting
actually said something about the
possibility of the show coming back he's
really non-committal about the show
being over completely because obviously
we're living in a day and age where
Netflix is resurrecting a lot of dead
shows there's totally the possibility
that you can be seeing Futurama content
on the web in some form and they did say
that they all loved working together and
they'd be totally happy to all come back
if it was possible so start writing
emails to Netflix right now they also
talked a lot about the simpsons
crossover that Futurama is doing next
year so what's going to happen is that
either the series finale this year on
The Simpsons will be a crossover with
the Futurama characters it'll be
Futurama characters on The Simpsons that
is or it will be the season premiere in
the fall of 2014 so you'll definitely
see Futurama on The Simpsons in 2014
either just either happen in the spring
or in the fall I did get to go up and
ask them a question on camera I just
asked them what their favorite fry meme
was and David X Cohen said that it was
basically the original one shut up and
take my money and Billy West actually
even did it for camera I'll try and post
a link to that video but you did that
shut up and take my money like live on
camera it was really funny the really
cool thing is is that I was actually
sitting behind someone so I couldn't see
Billy West up on stage but I could hear
his Frye voice and the funny thing is is
the
that's his normal voice the fry voice is
how he talks normally so it sounded like
Philip J fry was just standing on stage
just talking it was so surreal and
really funny so here's my review of the
actual finale it wasn't my favorite
episode of Futurama ever but I don't
think I've ever watched a show where the
series finale was my favorite episode so
that's not totally abnormal because it
was the finale it was much more
emotional than any of the other stories
like Jurassic Park that was a real
tearjerker but they also say that it was
a big fan favorite so I think that they
thought when they were gonna make this
really really emotional and kind of tie
up a lot of storylines that it would
kind of resonate with fans in the same
way the more emotional episodes did and
I certainly felt that it does a really
good job of tying up the fry and Leela's
story they did say that they kind of
painted themselves into a horner with
resolution to their relationship so if
the show ever does come back they're
kind of locked in to that but it's not
something that fans will object with so
I don't think it's a big problem overall
the tone of the final parts of the
episode were fairly neutral just because
they said they didn't want to piss
everyone off by making it super dark and
just killing everyone and they didn't
want to make it too happy just because
they felt that that would ring to false
as well so overall Futurama is really
big on the idea of the sitcom reset and
they talked a lot about this idea where
they get into all these crazy situations
and the science of things kind of takes
them to these really far places but by
the time the next episode airs they
always have to be back to normal
so overall I do felt the finale kind of
made it seem that way without completely
resetting everything how mad would you
have been as a fan if everything on this
series had been boiled down to like a
dream in benders head and just a bunch
of ones and zeroes so I'm really am
happy with the actual way that it ended
it's real whatever ends up happening at
the end of this episode if you haven't
seen it yet it lasts it's it's permanent
so if you totally are a fan of the show
hypnotoad can totally bring this back be
sure to hold out hope for some more web
content and crossovers with the Simpsons
as long as the Simpsons is alive
Futurama can always come back like I
said earlier this week I'll be posting
my next game of Thrones Season 4 preview
that'll be for Arya be sure to subscribe
to get it
it'll be posting on Friday if you didn't
see it already I did a video for
Benedict Cumberbatch playing this
Indiana Jones type character you can
click here to get that thanks so much
for watching
Oh glory to it